[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اصول الغرب وانطفاء جدوته
وخذلانه وخيانته للقيم التي رفعها وصولا
الى عالم بلا معالم وما مر عبرها من
انتاجات فكريه وثقافيه انطلقت من دراسه
الخطاب الاحتجاجي للحركات الامازيغيه
والاسلاميه في المغرب والتي كانت المبحث
الذي نال عنه درجه الدكتوراه يمكن تلخيص
مسيره ضيفنا الدكتور حسن اريد الفكريه
انشغل الرجل بفهم واقع بلاده ومجتمعه اولا
وفهم المحيط المغاربي المتشضي طوال عقود
ما بعد الاستقلال وكذلك محاوله فهم
التراجع العربي اتساقا مع فهم القوى التي
تسيطر على العالم ومالات قوتها وهيمنتها
ونفوذها يشكل الدكتور اريد حاله نادره في
واقع المثقفين العرب فقد ترفع عن البقاء
في دوائر السلطه ومناطق نفوذها وبحر
امتيازاتها معبرا عن رغبه جارفه بالتحليق
في عوالم الفكر والبحث متسلحا
بالاستقلاليه والفهم مغايره غير المقيد
بمنصب او وظيفه او سلطان ولطالما ذهب
الرجل الى التاريخ والسيره فقد يجد من
خلالها مساحه اوسع للحديث والتعبير وفي
كتابه رواء مكه الذي اثار ضجه واسعه وحقق
ارقاما كبيره في طلب الاقتناء من قبل
القراء تناول الرجل جانبا من تجربته في
القصر وهي التجربه الغنيه التي ساعدت على
تشكل افكاره ورؤيته الاكثر دقه لما يجري
في البلاد والعالم استضيفه الليله لمراجعه
معظم هذه الاعمال وافكارها الرئيسيه التي
طرحت جدلا مهما في الساحه الثقافيه
المغربيه والعربيه الدكتور حسن اريد
المثقف والكاتب المغربي ضيف المقابله في
الجزء الثاني فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بك دكتور سعداء بوجودك في هذا الجزء
الثاني في الجزء الاول تناولنا المسيره
والحقيقه في امر ما تعمقنا فيه بشكل كبير
وهو امر في غايه الاهميه يتعلق بالجانب
السياسي لديك تجربه سياسيه في المغرب
خلاصتها امرين ما يحدث المغرب على الصعيد
الداخلي التحولات المهمه واللافته تجاه
الاصلاح المغرب في 2012 و 2011 ربما من
البلدان العربيه الاستثنائيه الذي اوجد
مواءمه خاصه به
لا تغير في طبيعته تماما ولكنها تقدمت به
الى الامام نحو المشاركه الشعبيه والمساله
المهمه التي نهتم بها نحن المشارقه هذا
الاشكال الدائم بين المغرب والجزائر
انت تخصصت في عملك الخارجيه في موضوع
الاتحاد المغاربي ونواته وعايشته هذا
الامر اريد ان تلخص لنا هذا الامر لانه
يبدو مركزيا ومفتاحا مهما لفهم السياسه
الخارجيه المغربيه هذا الاشكال الدائم
الذي لا ينتهي بين المغرب والجزائر والذي
لا يبدو انه في طريق تسويه عادله للطرفين
ومثل ما قلت معقد
ككل العلاقات الاسريه لانه نتحدث
عن شعب واحد موزع بين دولتين المغرب
والجزائر شعب واحد نفس البنيه الذهنيه نفس
التركيبه
البشريه الى اخره وهذا هو الذي يجعل
المشكل حقيقه عويصه لا اظن انه من الحكمه
ان نبدا من التاريخ ولكن يبدو لي ان ان
حقيقه العلاقات المغربيه الجزائريه تعاني
مما اسميه او ما يمكن ان اسميه بلعنه
المواعيد المخلفه
كان من الممكن ان يتم لقاء بين الملك
الحسن رحمه الله ورئيس كوميديا رحمه الله
في 78 وتم الاتفاق ان يكون
اللقاء بين القائدين في
وحدث ان توفي الرئيس بومدين في ديسمبر ولم
يتم اللقاء
وكانت حقيقه فرصه مجهده ومخلفه
لقائدين لهما وزنهما وكاريزماهما
ومعرفتهما
المشكل القاعده قادر على الاحداث
بعد ذلك حقيقه
حدث انفراج في 88
وهذا الانفراج كانت فيه خطوات اذا طلعت به
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بدور اساس لقاء
ثنائي في 86 في الحدود بين المغرب
والجزائر بين
المرحوم الحسن الثاني والمرحوم الشاذلي
جديد وكان بدايه حلحله وهو الامر الذي
افضى الى
الى استئناف العلاقات في 88 وبدا مسلسل
حقيقه واعد
ام معاهده مراكش التي ترسل اتحاد المغاربي
تغير العالم العربي
في 90 91 اهتز العالم العربي بعد اجتياح
العراق الكويت وهذا الحدث كان له تاثير
كبير على بلاد المغرب
يعني اهتزت الجزائر مظاهرات مغرب نفس
الشيء يعني ليبيا ضربت بالحصار بعد كان له
تاثير يعني واظن كان له تاثير سلبي يعني
هذا الحدث
كان له تاثير سلبي لانه عطل مسيره الاتحاد
المغاربي يعني
للامانه ينبغي ان نقول بان الذي اثار
الصحافه الجزائريه تصريح للملك الحسن
الثاني رحمه الله في حوار مع جريده الشرق
الاوسط قال حين ان قال حينها انه كان من
المستحسن ان يتم احترام مسلسل الانتخابات
الذي جرى في الجزائر وكان يمكن ان تكون
لهذه التجربه مختبرا يعني استعمل هذا هذه
الكلمه اختبرني كل الدول المغرب ليس فقط
للدول بل للعالم العربي ان تكون هناك
تجربه لاسلاميين في الحكم
فكانت هذه الجمله
اغضبت واثارت حفيظه الصحافه وكانت ربما هي
النقطه يعني
التطور حقيقه يعني لكن الموضوعيه
الموضوعيه لم يكن الملك الحسن صاحب الفكره
صاحب فكره ان تكون هذه التجربه يعني عباره
عن او تجربه
او الرئيس
شادي ابن جديد يعني هناك حوار
بوسه مؤخرا
لجريده
يابانيه قال فيه
جديد بانه كان يرى ويتوقع ان تكون هذه
التجربه يعني عباره عن مختبر الحسن الثاني
اخذ هذه الفكره عن عن
ولكن المهم وانها عنصر تحول
الى الان بدا نوع من الانفراج
بعدما عرفته الجزائر من مصالحه والتوافق
وانتخاب المرحوم عبد العزيز بوتفليقه في
ابريل 99 حقيقه كان هناك امل يعني من اجل
نوع من
انصح هذا التعبير التطبيع بين البلدين لا
ادري ان كان هذا التعبير موفق ولكن على كل
حال ان تعود الامور الى مجاريها بين بين
البلدين وحقيقه استبشر المغاربه خيرا
حينما حل المرحوم عبد العزيز بوتفليقه في
جنازه الملك الراحل الحسن الثاني يعني
حقيقه
بالاضافه الى رسائل وكان من المفترض ان
يلتقي
عبد العزيز بدء الرئيس عبد العزيز
بوتفليقه بالملك الحسن الثاني لكن توفي
الملك الحسن الثاني وايضا هنا نفس الشيء
يعني
لكن بدون شك يعني تفاصيلها طويله وتاريخ
طويل جدا
قضيه الصحراء هي قضيه المركزيه في الخلاف
هذا الذي يبدو ولو انه حقيقه الان اصبحنا
نسمع خطابا اخر بانه من الوجهه النظر
الجزائريه
ان جذور المشكل تعود الى ما قبل قضيه
الصحراء
ولذلك انا كان تحليلي دائما بان قضيه
الصحراء ليست هي جوهر المشكل ولكن وجه
المشكل
تماما يعني انه هناك مساله
ثقه بين النظامين
وان قضيه الصحراء هي التي تعبر عن هذا
المشكل ليست هي السبب ولكن هي المعبر لك
كلمه دكتور لافته تقول انه هم الاكثر من
يفهم الموضوع مساله الصحراء ثم بعدهم
بدرجه اقل الاسبان هل كان هناك اسهام
فرنسي في هذه الحاله المتوتره الدائمه بين
البلدين هو لفتره من المؤكد
من المؤكد وربما قبل 75
يعني على الاقل في الخطاب
الجزائري الرسمي
يعتبرون بانه بعض القوى اليمينيه في فرنسا
التي لم تقبل بجزائر مستقله وكانت تحن الى
الجزائر الفرنسيه كانت من دون شكلها تاثير
يعني
ولربما ارادت ان يكون المغرب عباره عن
جزائر يعني تسويه او حسب المصطلح الفرنسي
تعويض فكان من دون شك ان بعض العناصر
اليمينه كان لها هذا الشعور ومن دون شك
انها كانت تغذي يعني
[موسيقى]
الحزازات لكن لا ينبغي في نهايه المطاف ان
نلقي اللوم على الاخر على الاخر ينبغي ان
العربيه طبعا يعني هذا جزء ربما يعني وقد
يكون
صائبا لفتره لجيل عاش بين قوسين الجزائر
الفرنسيه فرنسا تغيرت
ولكن الوضع لن يتغير في علاقتنا المغربيه
الجزائريه دكتور اخذك للمغرب وانت رساله
دكتوراه كانت عن الخطاب الاحتجاجي في
الحركات الامازيغيه والاسلاميه 2012 تمت
عمليه تحديث للدستور المغربي احداث نقله
واختراق كبير تولى بعده يعني عبر اليه
انتخابات ديمقراطيه الاسلاميه في الحكم
حظروا بالاغلبيه اول الامر ثم مره اخرى ثم
فشلوا فشلا ذريعا في المره الاخيره
هل خفتت حاله الاحتجاج التي كانت التي كنت
اشرت لها او درست لها سواء في الحركات
الامازيغيه او الحركات الاسلاميه هل تمت
التسويه اليوم نموذجيه في المغرب
ومن دون شك ان الحركه الاسلاميه
يعني تخترقها اطياف هناك حركه اسلاميه
يمكن ان نسميها حاده او متطرفه بين قوسين
وهي التي كنت اعنيها يعني الحركه
الاسلاميه الحاده يعني لا تؤمن بتوارث
السلطه تعتبر بان هذا منافي لطبيعه
الاسلام
ولذلك يعني بالنسبه اليها لا تؤمن يعني
بالملكيه كما هو موجود في خطاب
جماعه العدل والاحسان مثلا لكن هناك اتجاه
معتدل الذي يعتبر بانه يقر بما يسمى
الثوابت الى اخره لا اظن بان الاتجاه
الاول تغير ولكن الاتجاه الثاني يعني
تغيرت الظروف التي جعلت
ممكنا ان يكون جزءا من اللعبه الظروف التي
عرفها العالم العربي مع الربيع العربي هم
سمي بالربيع العربي جعلت يعني خيار
الاسلاميين او ما يسمون بالاسلاميين
المعتدلين ما دام انهم لا يجادلون السلطه
شرعيه انهم قد يكونوا ان يكونوا مقبولين
بالنظر الى هذا السياق طبعا لا يمكن يعني
ان نحرم هذا الاتجاه من شعبيه يعني له
شرعيه وشعبيه شرعيه ديمقراطيه
وشعبيه بحكم تعبيره عن وجدان شرائح من
المغرب
لكن
وقعت غير تغير في
ومن دون شك في اعتقادي وقد قلت ذلك في
مناسبات
يبدو بانه
العهد الذهبي للحركه الاسلاميه وراءها
يعني تغيرت الخارطه ليس فقط في المغرب
ولكن في العالم العربي
واننا قد نعيش ما بعد موجه
الاسلام السياسي وهو الامر الذي افشلت
برايكاني يعني الى اي اي الاحتمالين يعني
نركن اكثر
دعنا نقول بانه ونعتمد على خطاب
الاسلاميين انفسهم ممن يعتبرون بانهم
اساءوا التقدير وانهم راهنوا على السلطه
عوض ان يراهنوا على الجماهير فاظن بان
نسبه الخطا هي بالاساس يتحملها حزب
العداله والتنميه
اعتبر مثلا بان بعض القوانين الانتخابيه
بدون الدخول في التفاصيل كانت وراء يعني
او كان يراد منها يعني تقليص حزب العداله
والتنميه والحاله ان هذا القانون هو الذي
انقذ حزب العداله اظن بان المشكل يتبناه
بالاساس يعني حزب العداله لكن في اطار
موجه تجتاح العالم العربي
بخصوصيه في كل حاله خصوصا في لان هناك قوه
دفع يعني لا يمكن ان نفصل بلاد المغرب عن
المشرق الاسلام السياسي بالنسبه لك وراء
ظهرنا سيبقى مؤثرا ثقافيا ولكن العنوان
الاول ليس العنوان الاول سياسي حينما انا
اردت ان اخصص الحلقه هذه للمفكر دكتور حسن
اريد وانت نهايه علاقتك كرجل دوله وبعملك
في الدوله كان معه
الدور الذي منح لك مؤرخ المملكه المغربيه
في رواياتك لاحقا تحدثت او استخدمت مصطلح
او تعبير لافت عن ابرا من ان اتعافى من
المخزن ان اتعافى منه وكان يعني كان في
الامر حموله سلبيه كيف تمت عمليه الانتقال
ابي الرجل الدوله السياسي هنا سنعود الى
قضايا ذاتيه
والحال انني كنت اعتقد بان هذه الحلقه
ستنكبوا بالاساس على القضايا الثقافيه
الجسر هو انه كان من الضروري ان اعبر عن
هذا التحول
يعني لشخص كان في جزء من المنظومه ولم يعد
من المنظومه لا بد او على الاقل يعني ان
اسفر عن هذه الهويه الجديده وهو الامر
الذي عبرت عنه في رواء مكه الذي ليس روايه
ولكن بوح بوح رواء مكه هو 2017 تماما ولو
انني كتبته قبل ذلك التاريخ
بل كتب كتبته الليله التي
يعني التي اعتزمت فيها يعني تقديم
طلب يعني حينما سترت اخر سطر من هذا البوع
وكان يوم الثلاثاء يوم الاربعاء يعني طلبت
لذلك ولكنني لم انشره الا الى خمس سنوات
بعد ذلك التاريخ هذا الكتاب
اعرب فيه او يعني اعلن فيه عن هويه جديده
يعني هويه جديده يعني ملامحها
ملامحها ان هي في نهايه المطاف انني اخترت
خيارا اخر غير ذلك الذي كنت فيه يعني
وان هناك لحظه مفصليه
من دون شك انني
قيامي بالحج كان تحولا بالنسبه الي ولكن
هذا التحول كان تعبيرا عن توجه
وكنت اعيش نوع من التوزع بينما انتهيت
اليه وبينما كنت اعيشه ولذلك لكي اكون
منسجما مع نفسي يعني
طلبت الاعفاء لكي اكون في
اتساق مع الرؤيه والرؤى التي اخذت يعني
ولم يكن ممكنا في اطار يعني طقوس معينه
وضوابط معينه ان اخلص لمن انتهيت لابد ان
هناك شيء كبير كان ينتظرك الذي يدفعك
للتخلي عن امتيازات ومكانه رجل الدوله
والوظيفه المتقدمه والعوائد الكبيره
والامتيازات الدنيويه لابد ان ثمه امر كان
يجد بك ما هو وربما
احساس مثل ما يقال في مثال يحصل بالمرء
ان يكون الاول في قريته
على ان يكون الثاني في روما هذه حكمه
رومانيه
فبالنسبه الي ان اكون اولا في قريتي في
شيء ولو صغر هذا طالع به اهم بالنسبه الي
من شيء سوري هذا بالنسبه الي يعني ولو كان
يعني يقترن بالحظوه وبالامتيازات
ممكن
يعني زاويه يمكن ان الوذ بها وهي القراءه
والكتابه وهي التي انقذتني منه
[موسيقى]
بعد ان نزع الدكتور حسن اريد رداء السياسي
كانت تحول الى عالم الفكر الذي وجده اكثر
اتساقا مع تكوينه وما يربو اليهم وينظر
الى اريد اليوم باعتباره احد اكثر
المثقفين والمفكرين المغاربه والعرب غزاره
في الانتاج وتنوعا في الحقول التي يكتب
فيها ومن السياسه الى الادب مرورا
بالتاريخ جاءت مؤلفات حسن اريد لتعبر عن
قلق دائم واهتمام حثيث بالمجريات مغاربي
وعربيا بل وعالميا بالتصريح تاره والترميز
تارات اخرى
وساهم اتقان اريد للغات العربيه
والانجليزيه في انفتاح على البحوث
التاريخيه والاجتهادات الفكريه والابداعات
الادبيه فجاءت افكاره معبره عن اطلاعه
الواسع تعاقبت اصدارات الرجل ومقالاته في
كثير من الجرائد والمجلات والمواقع
الالكترونيه كما كان حريصا باستمرار على
عرض افكاره من خلال المحاضرات التي يلقيها
ويتولى الدكتور اوريد مناصب ثقافيه عده
فهو رئيس لمركز طارق بن زياد للدراسات
والابحاث ومستشار علمي لمجله زمان
باللغتين العربيه والفرنسيه الى جانب
استاذيته بجامعه محمد الخامس في العاصمه
المغربيه الرباط
وكتبت كثيرا كتبت في الادب كتبت في وفي
الفكر وهو الاهم استعرض بعض المحطات
الرئيسيه وفول الغرب كان كتابا لافتا وظهر
مع شيخ الازهر وتعرض الرجل لحمله
وحقيقه اول كتاب ربما
اسفرت عنه عن هذا التوجه والذي كان النواه
اولى لهذا الكتاب هو مراه الغرب المنكسره
وانطلقت من تقييم الازمه التي كان يعيشها
الغرب في سنه 2008 ماليه واعتبرت بانها
اكثر من ماليه واكثر من اقتصاديه بل
وجودها كيف لانه في نهايه المطاف الغرب
لوح بقيم اعتبارها قيم عالميه وكونيه وان
تاريخ انتهى حسب المقوله الماثوره
وتبين او تبينا كلنا بانه
القيم يعني اولا مجروحه يعني الليبراليه
يعني الاقتصاديه او نيو ليبراليه افضت الى
استفحال الفقر وغنى الاغنياء يعني كان
يقال بانه حسب ما يسمى بتوافق واشنطن انه
يكفي ان تخلق ثروه لكي تعم كل الشرائح
والحال ان الذي حدث هو العكس هو انه اغتلت
فئه
وتوسعت دائره الفقر والهوى بين الذين
يملكون والذين لا يملكون الازمه الماليه
تماما ثم كذلك فيما يخص القيم قيم
الديمقراطيه كان من العسير في نهايه
المطاف القول بالديمقراطيه والانسان يرى
مجترحته الولايات المتحده في العراق في
2003 كانت عمليه اقتصاد بعد يعني عمليه
تجويع الى اخره
فالغرب الذي كان ينادي
بحقوق الانسان كان اول من يغتالها سجن ابي
غريب مثلا
مسلسل لا نهائي من خيانه فلذلك يعني كيف
حقيقه لانه في نهايه المطاف التربيه تقاس
بالقدوه لا يمكن ولا يمكن لدوله كانت
تعتبر نفسها بانها ترسل نظام العالمي
الجديد والامه الضروريه ان تكون اول من
يخرق
الامم او ميثاق الامم المتحده
وتشون حرب من دون تفويض الامم
المتحده وتفرد توجهات من غير المعنيين
بالامل فهذه التناقضات هي التي اسفرت عنها
وقضايا اخرى مرتبطه بحريه التعبير كيف ان
حريه التعبير في نهايه المطاف تفضي في
حقيقه الامر الى
امتلاك او توجيه حريه او حتى فيما يخص
الحريه يعني الجنسيه الى اخره بتعبير اخر
الغرب الذي كان يزعم يعني رفع قيم الانوار
كان اول من يخون هذه القيم طيب الغرب
لصالح ماذا ولصالح وفول الغرب لابد ان
اقول بان هذا العنوان لم اختاره
لم اختاره اختاره الناشر ومنذ حقيقه
الحمله التي اثارها اصبحت حريصا الا اترك
الناشر يختار العنوان لانه
بالاساس يعني كتب باللغه الفرنسيه وباللغه
الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
واثيرت ضجه يعني حينما يعني كان فضيله
الشيخ الازهر مع الكتاب معه لقطه في
الطائره
فكان يقرا هذا الكتاب
وانبرت وانبرت بعض الاوساط في مصر في
انتقاد قبيله طبعا ان يقرا هذا الكتاب ليس
معناه انه يتبنى لا وفول الغرب ولا روايه
وهذا سطحيه في اعتقادي في في انك تقول
دكتور
العالم العربي هي انعكاس للازمه التي يعيش
الغرب
لماذا وكيف ما تفصيل هذه الفكره هو في
اعتقادي يعني
سيطول بنا الحديث لكن العناوينها الرئيسيه
ولكن عناوينها هو انها لم نخرج الى الان
من التركيبه التي وضعتها بريطانيا بعد
الحرب العالميه الاولى يعني الهندسه هي
التي ارسلتها بريطانيا وما كان يسمى
او اللحظه
البريطانيه
اول شيء يعني امتلاك موارد البترول
ولذلك كل التقسيمات التي كانت ثم بعده
ثم بعده وعد بلفور الى اخره
والوقوف وهذا واقع امام اي مشروع توحيدي
هاته القواعد الناظمه التي وضعتها
البريطانيا هي التي ستثير عليها الولايات
المتحده بعد الحرب العالم العربي
فالمسرحيه
كتبتها بريطانيا يعني واصبحت الولايات
المتحده تشخص المسرحيه فيما سمي باكس
امريكانو او او السلم
الامريكي بتعبير اخر رسم الشرق الاوسط
وانعكاس على البلاد المغرب في غياب
المعنيين بالامر وطبعا هنا يتقاطع تحليل
مع تحليل
شخص فلسطيني لبناني المرحوم سمير قصير في
كتيب حقيقه
مفيد للغايه تاملات حول الماسات العربيه
هو كتبه باللغه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
هذا القرب من من الغرب
هو الذي يؤجج هاته العلاقه يعني علاقه
الغرب بالهند ليست هي علاقه الغرب
والاهميه المرتبطه بالموقع
وما يترتب عن الموقع من تاريخ سجالي يعني
[موسيقى]
من الصليبين وقبل الصليبيين
النخب الثقافيه في ادراك هذه الازمه وفي
محاوله ايجاد مخارج لها خصنا ازمه طويله
الامر ليس هناك مجتمع تطور من دون النخب
ومن اضطلاع النخب بدور اساسي هذا معطاه
اساسي يعني
ولا يمكن حقيقه ان نقول بان النخب في
العالم العربي غائبه ولكن مغيبه لفتره كنت
اتمنى تحليل
الكاتب والمسؤول السياسي مروان معشر الذي
كان يقول بان النهضه العربيه او اليقظه
العربيه على الاصح الاولى كانت شان نخب من
دون جماهير وان اليقظه العربيه التي
بالاساس بزغت مع الربيع العربي هي نقده هي
يقظه جماهير من دون نخب كنت حقيقه ارى ذلك
الان لا ارى ذلك لا يمكن ان نقول بان
العالم العربي لم يفرز نقبا فكريه ولا
سياسيه ولكن غائبه عن مركز القرار هذا هو
المشكل
هذا هو المشكل هو هذا يعني التعتيم على
هذه النقاب ولكن القول بانه يمكن ان نرتكن
فقط الى مقاربات تقنيه لاشخاص يدبرون
قضايا دقيقه هذا لا يمكن ان يقول لا اظن
ذلك
السلطه والتاثير في القرار
للتاثير عبر الكتابه وعبر الراي وعبر
التفكير وهذا امر مهم لكن تاثير ذلك اقل
مما يعني ان ما يوضع في السلطان اكثر
تاثيرا مما يوضع في القران حتى هو نتفق
معك
ولكن يحصل ان يكون هناك تاثير الاوضاع على
تاثير صفر حينما في نهايه المطاف يعني
ما يستشعر مثقفا التاثير صفر صفر اظن بانه
ينبغي ان يرتكن الى الكلمه والى الفكر
طبعا الفكر بالاساس ومثل البذره نزرعها
ولا ندري متى في نهايه المطاف يمكن
ان تثمر او تؤتي اكلها الى اخره ولكن لابد
في نهايه المطاف لمجتمع يعني ان ينتج
مفكرين ثم حقيقه الفكر
هو من المهام التي يتاح فيها للشخص ان
يخطئ كل او على الاقل هناك مهن لا يسمح
فيها الخطر لا يمكن ربان الطائره ان يخطئ
او الجراحه ان يخطئ المفكر يمكن ان يخطئ
ومن المستحسن ان يقتل ان يجرب لانه في
نهايه المطاف المجتمع
يستقي او يستخلص العبره من خطا المثقف
فربما ميزه المثقف هو انه الشخص او يخطئ
كثيرا يقود
فهذا ربما هو من ميزات الاشخاص انا لا
استعمل كلمه مفكره وكذا على الذين
يشتغلون في الفكر يقودني الى عالم بلا
معالم والذي ايضا شخصت فيه الحاله
العالميه تحدثت عن انهيار يعني عن حاله
التعدديه القطبيه الانتهاء منها ازمه
اتحاد الاوروبي ازمه الديمقراطيه وافكار
الرئيسيه هامه
اين كانت بوصلتك ماذا تريد بالضبط ان ان
تقول من هذا كنت اقول بان السماء كانت
غائمه السماء العالم
بتعبير بعض الشعبويه
بتعبير يعني مجازي كنت ارصد حاله الجو
العالميه يعني وكان غائما وينذر بالعاصفه
وقعت العاصفه والتي هي الحرب
روسيا الاوكرانيه طبعا
وقفت على تشخيص الوضع اولا انتهاء او ازمه
الاحاديه القطبيه يعني تبين في نهايه
المطاف بانها لم تكن ايجابيه مع بروز
فاعلينا كثر ومنهم بالاساس الصين ثم بعده
روسيا وازمه
الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا واقعي الان هذا واقع
من العسير الان ان نتحدث
عن الدمقرت ونحن نرى حال حتى الديمقراطيات
العريقه مع موجه الشعبويه فلذلك انا حقيقه
حاولت ان ارصد هذا الواقع
ومثل ما يقول شكسبير في في بيت شهير له
يعني كل سماء
ملبده لابد ان تمطر لكي يصحو الجو هناك
يعني اشكال جدلي حول الديمقراطيه انه هل
الديمقراطيه كنظام اليوم هو النظام التام
والنهائي الذي يجب ان تقتدي فيه الدول
واضح انه في شكوك كبيره في هذه المساله مع
ما تتيح الديمقراطيه من من عيوب ومن
اشكاليات ومن الصعود الشعبويه الخطاب
المتطرف وما الى ذلك وانها ليست نظاما
تاما ونهائيا
ونموذجيا يمكن ان يقتدي فيه الجميع حسب
كيف ننظر الى الديمقراطيه لا يمكن ان
نختزل الديمقراطيه في الانتخابات
ديمقراطيه تقوم على قواعد في بايجاز شديد
هو سياده الشعب ان كثره الاساسيه هي هي
القاعده
اذا لم تكن الشعب الشرعيه مستمده من الشعب
فتصبح يعني
ديمقراطيه او لعبه
ولكن حينما يكون الشعب هو مصدر الشرعيه
حينها يمكن ان نتحدث عن عن الديمقراطيه
الديمقراطيه لا تلغي التوتر او الصرع ولكن
تسعى ان تلطف ان يتم هذا الصراع بطرق
منظمه منظمه يعني بتعبير اخر يعني تصريف
العنف لكن
هذه فهي ليست احسن نظام ولكن
اقلها سوى في الاشتراطها دكتور بالحموله
القيميه الغربيه
هو طبعا الغرب يعتبر
بانه
بانها قيم كونيه واظن بانه التشوف للحريه
وللعداله والكرامه هذه قيم كونيه
مثلما نستعمل
وحده قياس الزمن برزت في الغرب الكيلومتر
متر الى اخره ولا نستعمل الذراع والشبر
والباع يعني فلا باس ان نستعمل هذه القياس
ليست قيم للغرب الكونيه لكن المشكله هو
انه حتى في داخل الغرب اصبحت الديمقراطيه
في ازمه يعني عاد العنف
سترات الصفراء في فرنسا
لاقتحام مبنى الكابيتول في الولايات في
واشنطن يعني التهديد باستعمال
السلع عدم قبول يعني الاحتكام الى الى
صناديق هذا كله حقيقي وطبعا الديمقراطيه
بالنسبه للغرب ليست مجرد تقنيه لتدبير
العلاقه بين الحاكم والمحكوم هي بالاساس
عنصر اساسي من هويه الغرب عشرت الى معطى
جديد دكتاتوريه رقميه في الكتاب لماذا هو
مصطلح ليس مصطلحي ولكن انا تبنيت
في ميدان يمكن ان اقول فيه بانني متطفل
الانسان اصبح عاريا بمصطلح
فيلسوف فرنسي يعني
يعني التكنولوجيا او الثوره الرقميه جعلت
الانسان يعني يمكن ان نعرف كل حتى حميميته
في نهايه المطاف
وهذه الحميميه في نهايه المطاف تحد من
حريه الشخص لابد ان نحترم مجالا من حميميه
الاشخاص والواقع ان القوانين لم تتطور
تطورت
الميكانيزمات والاليات من دون ان تفرز
المجتمعات يعني ترسانه قانونيه لحمايه
حميميه الافراد وهذا الذي يفضي الى ما
يسمى بدكتاتوري او الديكتاتوريه الرقميه
دكتور ترى بان عالما قديما قد مات لكن
عالما جديدا لم يولد بعد هو هذا الذي اراه
اي عالم الذي مات تحديدا والعالم الذي
عشناه بعد سقوط حائط برلين عالم قيل بانه
سيسوده او ستسوده قيم الليبراليه وقيم
الديمقراطيه هو العالم الذي قيل بانه
يحتاج الى قاطره وان هذه القاطره هي
الولايات المتحده والعالم الذي قيل عنه
بانه يحتاج الى امه ضروريه وهي الولايات
المتحده اظن موضوعيا بانه
حصيله الولايات المتحده في اداره المنطقه
او العالم عفوا بما فيها منطقه الشرق
الاوسط لم تكن ايجابي الى روسي قبلت
مجموعه من النخب ذهبت الى رواندا قبل
في تركيا قابلنا ايضا من الكل يتحدث على
انه لا يجب على هذا الغرب ان يضع لنا يعني
مواصفات كيف نعيش وكيف نحيا وكيف ندير
حياتنا نعم هناك قبول جزئي ببعض الانظمه
لكن لا يجب على الغرب ليس مؤهلا ان يضع
لنا الوصفه الكامله لكيف نعيش وبالتالي
واضح انه في احتجاج عالمي على على هذه
الهيمنه الان من خلال هذا الامر اي عالم
جديد ممكن ان ينتظره
ولابد ان نحدد مفهومنا للغرب الغرب ليس
مصطلحا سهلا ان نحدده لانه
ليس الغرب بالضروره السياسات السياسات
التي تقوم بها دول الغربيه يعني لا يمكن
في نهايه المطاف كما انه لا يمكن يعني ان
نعتبر تعذيب المجاهدين في الجزائر
والتعبير عن قيم الثوره الفرنسيه
ولا يمكن كذلك ان نعتبر بان من قيم
الغربت الولايات المتحده في العراق
والسجن ابي غريب وتجويع الشعب العراق
فلابد حقيقه ان نميز بين قيم
يعني برزت في الغرب
من اجل اعلاء كرامه الانسان
من اجل التركيز على الحريه والحريه مفهوم
اساسي
والذي جعل امه صغيره تقود العالم وهي
انجلترا هو بالاساس قيمه الحريه
ولذلك حينما نتحدث عن الغرب لابد ان نحدد
يعني طبعا الغرب الاستعلائي لاستغلال هذا
مرفوض يعني ولكن قيم تروم كرامه الانسان
يعني وحريه الانسان والعداله لا اظن بان
عاقل يمكن ان يرفضها لكن دكتور يعني مثلا
اكيد مؤخرا بدانا يعني بدات القيم الغربيه
حتى الاجتماعيه فيما يتعلق بالمثليه
بالمراه كل هذه يراد فرضها كما هي وانها
تصبح هي المسطره التي يقيم على اساسها
تقيم على اساس الانظمه والشعوب المجتمعات
واي شيء وان اي شيء لا يشبه او لا يلتزم
بهذه الاولويات ليس عالميا من دون شك ان
هناك ما يسمى مركزيه غربيه يعني يعتبر
اكيد
وانا لست هنا في يعني للدفاع عن الغرب
ولكن لابد ان نقر لان التفكير يبدا حينما
يبدا التمييز لا نلقي الامر كليه ولا
نقبله كليه لابد ان ندرس كل حاله على حده
طبعا
المثليه ليست قيمه يعني ليست قيمه لكي
تفرض ولا يمكن من شخصيا يعني ان اقول بذلك
من دون شك ان الغرب يعي بانه يعيش مرحله
مفصليه يعني او حقبه شديده يعني وانه في
ازمه هذا حتى الغربيون انفسهم يوقرون بذلك
يعني
ولذلك يتحتم علينا في اعتقادي وانت كنت
يعني شاهدا على حوار شيق مع وائل حلاق
فانه ينبغي ان نقوم بقراءه نقديه للغرب لا
يمكن في نهايه المطاف يعني ان نبقى
متفرجين وربما انت اشرت الى رواء مكه انا
تبينت في نهايه المطاف انني كنت اسكن بيتا
لم اكن مالكا له تبينت بان هذا البيت الذي
كان يعتبر بيتا لكل للعالم كنت فقط يعني
اقطنه بدون اوراق ثبوتيه وان من حق صاحب
البيت ان يخرجني وتبينت بانه يتصرف بانه
مالك ولذلك كان لزاما علي ان ابحث على بيت
اسكنه بيت لي
وجدت هذا البيت نعم هو في حاله من الترهل
والبلا الى اخره ولكنه بيتي
ولكنه بيتي
فوجدت في هذا البيت القديم دره وهي
الاندلس واظن بانه لدي شرعيه بان احيي هذه
طبعا
تقول انه شغفك مش مرتبط بالمرحله الزمنيه
وكذا شغف منه اخر شغف مرتبط بالفكره لانه
ليس من الحكمه يعني ان نسترجع او تعود بنا
العقارب الى الماضيه او استرجاع الاندلس
كذلك
هذا غير مجدي فلست احن الى الاندلس لا
الرقعه ولا الزمن ولكن للفكره
فمن دون شك يعني تناقضات التي بدات في
سلوكات الغرب هي التي افرزت ردود فعل
وعوض ان تكون هذه الردود انطباعيا ينبغي
ان تنبني على على معرفه
او محاوله التنبؤ دكتور في اي عالم جديد
ينتظرنا اذا كنا يعني وافقنا جدلا انه هذا
العالم القديم قد مات ثم تعال عالم جديد
الان يعني يمر بانتظار ان يتسجد العالم
الصين ليست جاذبه روسيا وهذه يعني هذا
نموذج نموذجها غير قابل للانتشار بشكل
كبير يعني كيف نتوقع ملامح هذا العالم
وانا ساقول من هو احسن مني موقعا
ودرايه
وهو من كان وزيرا للخارجيه الامريكيه
ومستشارا في الامن القومي بالتون جون
بولتون في كتاب الله قال فيه بان معالم
العلاقات الدوليه المقبله ستتحدد العلاقات
البينيه الامريكيه الصينيه
فكما تحددت العلاقات الدوليه في القرن
التاسع عشر بين فرنسا
وبريطانيا ولفتره بين بريطانيا والمانيا
ثم بعد ذلك بين الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
السوفياتي اظن بان العلاقه بين الفاعلين
الكبيرين في عالم الغد هو الولايات
المتحده والصين دخولها وهو واضح الامر
يعني يعني واضح تمدد هواء زياده نفوذها في
اي اتجاه يمكن ان يؤثر دخول لاعب مثل
الصين بخلفيته وحمولته وثقافته وتاريخه
يعني في الصين لا في لا في حقوق الانسان
لا في ديمقراطيه لافعاء هذا مؤكد في
اقتصاد فيه اقتصاد ولكن اكثر من اقتصاد
اول شيء الصين او الصينيون يعبرون عن
انفسهم بانهم حضروا وليس فقط دوله او امه
يعني
تحديد الصين بالنسبه للصينيين يتجاوز
مفهوم الدوله والدوله القوميه الوطنيه
لتناسيو كما برزت في الغرب الصينيون
يشعرون بانفسهم انهم حاملون
لحضاره ثانيا
الصين التي نتحدث عنها لها قوه ناعمه فهو
الامر الذي لم يكن مثلا الاتحاد السوفياتي
وثالثا
ما هي القوه نعم التي تتملك
اقتصاد تقنيه وصولها لكل اصول في بيت لا
توجد شيء يعني مرتبط بالصين يعني وهو
الامر الذي لم يكن الاتحاد السوفياتي لم
تكن له قوه نائمه انت جاذبيه ثقافيه لديها
ولكن اصبحت تقل انت اشرت الى كتابي
واعتمدت على
معايير
اقامها امريكيون انفسهم بان جاذبيه
الولايات المتحده جامعتها طبها الى اخره
اخذ يقلد وعلى كل حال
للصين قوه ناعمه
ولديها رؤيه او ما يسمى بالحلم
الصيني الصين لم تعد مجرد في نهايه المطاف
مصنع كما كانت تعرف يعني مصنع العالم الى
اخره ولكن اصبحت مثل ما يعبر عنها
الصينيون بانها ذئب محارب وان لديها
الكلمه لكي او لديها الحق او الشرعيه
لتقول كلمتها والان اصبحنا نرى بانها تحدد
يعني اصبحت فاعلا حتى
هذا في اعتداء طبعا هذا في اعتراق اختراق
يعني
سيكون له اظن ذلك اظن ذلك ويذكر بنحو من
الانحاء ما عرفته المنطقه
بعد الاعتداء الثلاثي حينما ازاحت
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد السوفياتي
فرنسا وبريطانيا من الشرق الاوسط اظن لن
تزيح الصين
الولايات المتحده من الشرق الاوسط ولكن
ستزاحمها وعلى الاقل دول المنطقه اصبح
لديها يعني ظهير اخر تستطيع ربما التوازن
عبره مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كما
لم يكن في السابق تبين في نهايه المطاف
بان الحرب البارده كانت لها بعض المزايا
وهذا التوازن
واظن بانه الاحادي القطبيه لم تكن جيده
بالنسبه للعالم اظن انا في اعتقادي واظن
بان المنطقه التي تضررت اكبر من اي منطقه
من الاحاديه القطبيه هي منطقه الشرق
الاوسط او قل الى العالم العربي عموما
في حين ان الابداع يتيح مساحه اكبر
ولذلك يعني
اعبر في الاعمال
الادبيه عما لا استطيع البوح به
او التعبير ثم لابد في العمل الفكري ليس
من الضروري ان تظهر الذاتيه طبعا لكل شخص
ذاتيته ولكن في العمل الابداعي لابد ان
تظهر الذاتيه وبتعبير اخر يعني كل من
الاعمال الفكريه
ومن الاعمال الادبيه تعبر عن هاجس واحد هو
الخروج
مما كان يسميه الكواكب بالفطور كان يعتبر
بان العالم العربي يعيش فتورا
وغايته هو ان تسهم هاته الاعمال سواء كانت
الفكريه
او الادبيه الخروج من هذه الحاله التي مثل
ما قلت يعتريها ما سماه
الكواكب في
طبائع الاستبداد بالفتور
وربما عبر الادب يجد المثقف متسعا الحديث
عن عن واقع عبر اسقاطه في يعني حقب وفي
مواقع اخرى هو اتخذت تاريخ مختبرا حتى في
الاعمال
في الادبيه مثل مثلا زينه الدنيا
التي حاولت ان ارصد فيها ظاهره الاستبداد
من خلال الشخصيه نموذجيه يعني وهو ابن
عامر والذي قد يكون اي مستبعد عربي
الاسبان يعتبرون لهم تعبير عن ابن عامر
يسمونه بمكافيل العربي وحقيقه كان رجل
داهيه
وسياسي باهر وقائد عسكري ولكن بنسبه اليه
اخترته معبرا عن حاله
استبداد بل وما يعتري المستبد من حاله
نفسيه كذلك دكتور حسن اريد ان اشاكر مقدر
يعني ما منحتنا اياه من وقت شكرا في
حلقتين حاولنا نستعرض المسيره السياسيه
وعمل رجل الدوله وكذلك جوانب واضاءات على
المسيره الفكريه والادبيه شاكر ومقدر
وجودك في المقابله شكرا جزيلا استاذ علي
شكرا موصل لكم وانتم مشاهدينا الكرام على
الطيب المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله في
الاسبوع المقبل مع حلقه جديده من المقابله
دمتم بخير وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]